new york is a collection of villages the
old have been in charge since before the
revolution
until the new people invaded
well i'm new i've only just arrived you
are my niece and you belong to old new
york
[Music]
george russell is a power in the land
before long he'll put money into his
pocket with every train ticket you buy i
think we should know the russell family
we do not move in the same circles mama
you are encourageable i take that as the
highest praise well how do you find your
aunts zeta is kind but not clever
and agnes is clever but not kind
[Music]
mrs van reine and her sad sister were
spying on me today i don't know why you
bother with them i don't bother with
them i'm afraid new york can be quite
challenging at first we haven't found it
so have we joined there is no challenge
you are not equal to my dear
we have invited marion to live with us
prayers and a penny
i cannot live with an antagonist's
confines
you must meet the right people
in the right way
money isn't everything agnes
i don't understand why they have taken
you in i have a job and a fresh start
that i need i want to do something with
my life for a new yorker anything is
possible
you are the future mrs russell and if
you were the future the name must be the
past
well things move faster nowadays
i hope you're not against miscop she'll
disrupt things
maybe we need a bit of disruption let
the tournament begin
why don't we just go outside and roll in
the gutter it will save time
you know newport well miss russell the
mistress is not a player in the great
game that woman is unsuitable as an
acquaintance
[Music]
i'll make them pay one day how can
anyone be so rich
you
bastard i may be a bastard mr thorburn
but you are a fool and of the two i
think i know which i prefer
[Music]
you